[Music]
radio this one credit likely
inadvertently inspired the main
character from Madagascar I swear even
the still picture the zebra looks like
it's voiced by Chris Rock also look I'm
going to straight-up tell you the book
doesn't matter if I send the fact that
Dumbo has incredible ninja skills in
this movie don't tell me that the book
explains the time he trained with Ra's
al Ghul and the cemetery scene we don't
see such a scene in this and Dumbo
starts trunk full of all the Mort and I
sin that I don't want to hear it this
tightrope walking ballerina was so
committed to her craft she had her nose
removed to perfect her balance now
that's dedication god this movie is
oldest creation synchronize family
planning holy Disney missed a huge
opportunity to make a movie about a very
determined stork who tries to force an
adoption on a makeup artist from
Sacramento who try as they might just
can't seem to shake the stork no matter
how many disguises they try or dumpsters
they hilariously hide out it but make no
mistake the stork will use any means
necessary to force your Parenthood Miami
was attacked today by a barrage of
animal babies from the sky it's the
worst stork inflicted massacre since
2016 when storks was released also
though I'm very aware that babies are
delivered by storks but unless the ones
that deliver in Florida are different
than here they do not just parachute
them willy-nilly over an area think of
the lawsuits also also you mean the
entire circus is getting hundreds of
babies delivered today this is the most
amount of employee
pink since Lady Gaga performed at the
Oscars with Bradley Cooper why did the
stork deliver these five Tigers in the
same package when the bear got two
separate packages for two baby bears
they sorted by the father
I'm just saying papa bear might want to
ask some questions I think I just heard
April the giraffe yell as if all the way
from her purse Villa New York Tokyo
Subway's does the train need its own
song Jesus Christ 1941 we're only 5
minutes into this thing and we're
already entering our second song's
position I don't mind if you musical me
movie but at least lubricate me with
some dialogue in between
I'm not saying cartoons and fantasy
can't play loose with reality but
between this and Mary Poppins I'm
convinced that Disney is responsible for
me thinking clouds were like marshmallow
pillows up until a very embarrassing
moment in fourth grade science must be
right around here somewhere
you see this is the fatal flaw of baby
delivery via sicken a dissection how can
you coordinate that when you order
babies from the catalog if you're always
on the move also why does this stork get
to where a postal uniform while the
we saw earlier whirl regular ass-naked
storks damn it movie repeat after me
Florida does not border Mississippi
Florida is a horrible place to live
sorry I got distracted what were we
talking about why would this colorful
sparsely detailed map of the US tell you
where you can find a sign that tells you
where you can get gas four miles away
from the gas station oh that must be it
that must be what you mean you were
looking for a train so your directions
were tried to deliver this baby to the
circus but if you completely fail that
task try to find the train also it's
Tennessee I know Alabama Georgia and
Kentucky want to touch each other but
you got to get through Tennessee before
you start using the KY this train to
scale would be almost 100 miles long and
traveling through Florida at about
120,000 miles per hour Casey jr. is a
beast straight from heaven Bob here is a
baby for you too long sign here please
Maya's mrs. jumbo getting the singing
stalker graham service with signature
needed when the rest of the circus just
got their letters delivered by airmail
[Music]
you pack of hypocritical pachyderms now
you're all proud but mere seconds ago
when asked who was expecting you were
all like King elephants man it takes ten
full minutes for this one-hour movie to
deliver Dumbo the name of which you
might recognize is the title character
[Music]
I'm in a Disney early history filled
with racism this song might take the
cake a group of faceless black men
singing about slaving until they were
almost dead but not worrying about when
they get paid because when they do they
just throw their pay away and are
totally fine because they are
happy-hearted roustabouts one of the
lines is and I'm quoting here grab that
rope you hairy ape sometimes a simple
that's racist just isn't enough if you
can get elephants to hammer in this
manner then you should be able to get
all the other animals to do some work
too and oh yeah call all the newspapers
they trained elephants had a hammer why
the hell are Dumbo's mom's eyes red yeah
I see the symbolism but she's been angry
for quite some time and her eyes were
blue all the way until now also Disney
movies really hated moms back then
didn't they this is just a prelude to
Bambi PT Barnum dang this kids movie is
legit ruff
it's basically life is beautiful with
elephants this peanut is bigger than
pretty much this entire Mouse definitely
bigger than this mouths Mouse I mean
Mouse's mouth the cold-shoulder well
technically the cold l of analysis but
semantics why are you calling him by the
name the evil female elephants called
him did that name really stick name
names movie grow some balls and name
names did we really need the ringmaster
shadows striptease in this scene can we
get the point without being forced to
imagine his entire clan in 1941 watches
didn't have the number 6 on them I think
they were superstitious about it like
having a 13th floor at a hotel or
something in the ring climax you are now
getting that climax did um did this
Mouse just give the ringmaster an orgasm
because that's what I got out of the
scene how's the reception okay character
convinces another character to do
something by whispering in their ear
while they are sleeping cliche man yeah
it's 1941 but just go with it suddenly
from the sidelines and who is your
climax the word climax has been said
more than the word though in the last
two minutes
I checked after the ringmaster says here
climax has a 9 to 7 lead over kings um
um I'm guessing the ringmaster
understands these animals that the
animals speaking English so far could
actually express themselves if they want
it the proof is calling Dumbo by the
nickname the mothers gave him I'm
beginning to think these animals in
captivity is a much sadder story than
this movie is letting on now allocate
the always alarmingly anomalous and
annoyingly absurd alliterations around
here all right
amateurs this works I'm not kidding at
some point in this movie we will get a
flying elephant and I'd still be more
impressed by this game of jungle Jenga
in real life than that what does run out
jump on a spring board the show is going
on in front of an audience have they
really not practiced this yet ringmaster
really woke up the next day and said
elephants stuck yourselves while a baby
elephant springboard to the top of the
pyramid and they knew what you wanted
the ringmaster said something about this
is short like 10 elephants but then he
proudly exclaims it's impossible that
the movie forgot how many elephants
there were or the script accidentally
had a typo that was never fixed
absolutely no one and no animal dies
from this I'm no long there's no longer
I think it's possible that the matriarch
elephants are the most disgusting
villains in Disney history like worse
than lilo and stitch even this appears
to be real fire for a company that just
had full-size elephant projectiles
knocked down its entire big top they
don't appear to have learned any lessons
whose ensuring this deathtrap
I bet before when you remember Dumbo you
forgot about all the hardcore animal
cruelty someone to see ya
Alan's Dumbo struck all the way through
this window when just a few seconds ago
he could barely reach it
[Music]
I'm not crying about a non-existent baby
elephant you're crying about or not
existed baby elephant this mother Tiger
clearly received five kids at the
beginning of the movie but now there are
three and I'm beginning to think that
with the 17 elephants thing earlier and
this the movie is saying the animals at
this poorly run circus are experiencing
tragedies left and right later in life
these three would escape back to Africa
and then go on to assist in the murder
of Simba's dad sure it's ridiculously
unlikely that this series of events will
lead to a bottle of champagne being
poured into a water bucket which will
lead to Dumbo and his mouse friend
getting super drunk later but it's way
more unlikely that these drunk ass
clowns didn't finish that bottle and
that there's enough champagne to get a
baby elephant drunk
yeah underage drinking also as if we
haven't learned already not to go to
Disney for science the movie just all
the sudden decides that elephants can
drink through their trunks movie has
time for this this movie is 63 minutes
long people 10 minutes of it were
dedicated to storks and a train ride
they really didn't know what to do with
this Dumbo story arc did they it's about
to get weird yo apparently some of the
drugs from the 60s took a road trip to
the 40's just to write the next five
minutes of this movie also there are 16
minutes left in this movie did God make
it stop at least now we know where Ralph
breaks the internet got the idea from
also that blue elephant in the center
has no trunk I mean we all understand
why but still what is a freakin
trunkless elephant my nightmare fuel
tank is completely full what the it's
funny that this movie was made in part
to recoup the financial losses of
Fantasia but then they stuck a whole
Fantasia like sequence into this movie
anyway well our long national nightmare
is over what's that you say we enter
World War two in a month now no dead
people are going snow oh dude if you
were already skeeved out by these
jive-talking racial stereotype embracing
black crows just remember that the main
crow is named Jim Crow and voiced by a
white guy so basically he's doing an
animated minstrel show you know four
kids jump up Timmy the cue mouse is
talking under his breath here about
fifty feet down and fifty feet away from
these guys how on earth do they even
know what he said but
[Music]
Dumbo flying would have been a pretty
awesome way to fill this story up with
more dynamic storytelling but this
realization occurs with eight minutes
left in the film actually let me take
that back the song about the possibility
of Dumbo flying happens with eight
minutes left the realization occurs with
four minutes left
well unhappy Dumbo figured out his
special skill why couldn't he have just
learned this when he was being
mistreated by the clowns while being
made to jump off a fiery building into a
bunch of plaster instead we had to go
through a five minute psychedelic
journey followed by a bunch of crows
singing a song to get to this point
these news stories run through for
possible sequel ideas for this movie in
under 30 seconds I'd be happy that they
burned them here instead of making them
actual movies except that if you think
Disney won't do it anyway and we aren't
getting Dumbo goes to Hollywood in 2025
you haven't been paying attention
I can't believe it Americans fighting
Americans
[Music]
as the fellas it was sounding great but
I could have used a little more cowbell
[Music]
that wasn't flying that was falling with
style